[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis
j'espère que vous êtes bien sage mon
petit doigt me dit que beaucoup de
petits enfants oublient de faire leur
toilette et de se laver les dents avant
de se coucher
vous croyez pas trop oui nounours je
suis sûr qu'ils ne vont plus oublier le
patron je défends vite voire pas preneur
et nicolas ne traîne pas trop nous
suivrons les jeunes aiment faut manger
tâche à g qui veut devenir une grande
pie tient poopy une petite cuillère pour
papa
alors qu'est ce que j'entends notre
petit pipi de passage
elle est terrible elle veut rien mangé
et bien je vais l'agro dit nous ne
compte pas ma poutine nous tu vois je
crois qu'elle a sommeil ce vrai las de
tout p'tit sioux tu fais faire dodo on
va chanter notre berceuse tu vas vite
faire bateau fermeté jolie ziem à poupet
donne moi je veux la pure piano nous ne
soit pas trop bruit
no push to do wah c'est la fin de la
journée c'est le moment de se coucher
nous faisons comme nos amis millicent
monde où son nom c'est alan jean-phi sur
son nuage
j'en suis certain le marchand de sable
vient il nous dira fermez vos yeux et
dormait tous les deux non ça me vient
d'un autre lit non non tu nous fais ta
bonne nuit
sa grosse voix me ferait plaisir quand
j'avais mon
dormir non je vais monde hormis sa foi
nous fait plaisir
[Musique]
palmisano hôpitaux ne fera tout pour la
gta la lumière ball ne partons sans
faire de bruit nounours tout notre petit
monde dort déjà oui au souk au jeu les
hommes bonne nuit les enfants pauvres
[Musique]